let's go check in with Maurice in Zagreb
well we know that we have a lot of new
stops on the tour this year four to be
precise we already at Abidjan we're now
here in zagreb and the next one is going
to be in bucharest romania where we will
have the super bet rapid and blitz
events and with me is the general
manager of that organizing company super
bet organizer and sponsor of the company
Vlad our Juliano welcome to the show and
with the say we're really excited about
this happening in Bucharest your
thoughts on bringing chess to Romania
this year but we are definitely super
excited that we had this wonderful
opportunity to do something for
something big for the Romanian chess
movement I was a chess player myself
when I was a kid and this is a dream
coming through true for Romania so we
are super super excited and we are
preparing quite well I would say we are
bringing a nice surprises for this event
in Bucharest as we are preparing very
very well in terms of logistics in terms
of venue in terms of of the relationship
with the local chess federation and
speaking of venue I mean I'm so sad I'm
not gonna get to go because I here this
venue is simply top-notch elite and
we're getting graphics right now on the
screen well if you rate it like that yes
we we definitely love it it's the best
country club in Bucharest where you
would have all the facilities we have
really a big big venue where we can
accommodate not only the international
Grantchester but we can accommodate our
local tournament which is organized
together with the local federations so
our idea is to do this big international
event but also create some something for
the local chess players something like a
festival we will organise
similar event like Ranchester with the
local top chess players in Romania and
this is going to go for the senior
players also for the kids tournament so
we are trying to do three events in one
and we are really really looking forward
to create the best chess event in
Romania in in last year's it sounds
fantastic are you looking to get some
secrets from here as well as I why
you're spying in zagreb well yes I was
coming here to sneak in and and and and
still the best of logistics and
organization but I must confess that as
a chess player myself I came to see
those beautiful players and beautiful
games and very nice atmosphere that is
created around Grantchester you must
know Grandmaster Christian korilla is a
Romanian favorite son he's going to be
the one who is going to replace me there
I would say appropriately so of course
he is from Romania there must be
something special we are looking forward
to accommodate him we are very happy so
we are happy that we have Romanians in
this great movement of Grantchester so
yeah looking forward should be very
exciting yeah I'm excited
just seeing those pictures it will be
November 4th through 11th that you can
get to follow the show thank you so much
for joining joining us
it's a blocking glide our jelly I know
is that correct it is it's lauderdale
you are doing fine you know I got a
train to get these names right it's not
cz general manager of super bets they
will be organizing and sponsoring a
brand new tournament on the grand
Chester
thank you very much Wow